الجيش السوداني القوات الدعم السريع
باغتيال والي غرب دارفور بعد اختطافه وهو
منافته قوات الدعم دعيه لتحقيق في حادثه
القتل التي ادانتها مؤكده انها جاءت في
سياق صراع قبلي اتهمت الجيش بتاجيجه ياتي
ذلك في وقت تستمر فيه المعارك بين
المسلحين القبليين موقعة مزيدا من القتلى
والجرح ومتسببه باوضاع معيشيه صعبه دفعت
المدنيين للفرار
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
حيثيات تفجر الاوضاع في دارفور ومقتل والي
غربها في ظل تبادل الاتهامات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع حول المسؤوليه عماله اليه
الامور هناك وكيف نقرا مواقف مختلف
الاطراف من هذه التطورات
وكيف ستنعكس هذه المستجدات على اتفاق
السلام في دارفور وعلى صوره الكليه للمشهد
السوداني وما دلالات فتح جبهات جديده
للقتال في السودان وما هي رسائل الضغط من
ورائها ومن المستفيد
واي فرص لوضع حد للصراع واتساع رقعته على
ضوء المبادرات الافريقيه والاقليميه
والدوليه الراميه لوقف القتال والخروج من
الازمه
[موسيقى]
اخر ما كان السودان في حاجه اليه هو ان
يتاجج العنف اكثر في ولايه دارفور المسخنه
اصلا بصراعاتها وازماتها المزمنه عنف
متصاعد بلغ في واحده من ذراه تصفيه والي
غرب دارفور بعد تصريح انتقد فيه ممارسات
قوات الدعم السريع تلك التي نفت اي ضلوع
لها في خطفه وقتله دعيه لتحقيق مستقل في
ملابسات ذلك ما جرى ويستمر من صراع قبلي
في دارفور يتردد صباه بقوه في الداخل
والخارج حيث دانت بعثه الامم المتحده لدعم
المرحله الانتقاليه في السودان ما وصفته
بالعمل الشنيع مشيره في بيان لها الى شهود
عيان افادوا بتورط قوات الدعم فيه البعثه
طلبت بتقديم الجنات بسرعه الى العداله
والى عدم توسيع رقعه العنف في الولايه
الاتحاد الاوروبي تصفيه توالي غرب دارفور
ووصفها بالجريمه الوحشيه المروعه وقال
سفير الاتحاد لدى السودان ان حمايه
المدنيين ووصول المساعدات اليهم امران
ضروريان مشددا على ان المسؤولين عن
الانتهاكات سيخضعون عاجلا ام اجلا
للمساءله
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم حافظ
كبير الكاتب والباحث السياسي ومن اديس ابا
موسى
في شؤون الافريقيه وسيكون معنا عبر الهاتف
من الخرطوم عبد الماجد عبد الحميد الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي
ونبدا معك السيد حافظ كبير
لماذا وصلت الامور الى ما وصلت اليه في
دارفور ولماذا يقتل
ولي غرب دارفور لمجرد انه انتقد تصرفات
الدعم السريع
بهذا الشكل ما حيثيات ما حصل ولماذا
تحيه طيبه لك
ولضيوفك الكرامه للمشاهدين انا اعتقد ان
الاوضاع في غرب دارفور وتحديدا في الجنينه
هي كانت يعني منذ قبل اندلاع النزاع في
الخرطوم كانت اوضاع سيئه للغايه هناك
تداعيات لاشكالات قديمه اهليه وكذلك هناك
صراعات مسلحه عنيفه جرت خلال الفتره
الماضيه حتى قبل بدايه السلطه الانتقاليه
المدنيه وكذلك اثناء يعني اثناء السلطه
اثناء الحكومه الاولى بقياده محمد عبد
الله الدومه المحامي ابن الولايه لم يستطع
الدومه اخماد هذا الصراع صراع الاثني صراع
القبلي حتى جاء في فبراير من العام 2021
جاءت حكومه السلام
وانضم خميس بكر رئيس حركه تحرير السودان
ورئيس التحالف السوداني الى الحكومه
على راس الولايه كذلك استمرت الصراعات
القبليه وكانت هناك جهود مشتركه من قبل
اطراف مختلفه منها اطراف السلام وكذلك
هذه الصراعات سيد حافظ نعم هذه الصراعات
موجوده لكن كانت قد خفت وتيرتها قبل
الازمه الاخيره في السودان الان ما يحصل
في الجنينه وفي غرب دارفور هو امتداد كما
يقول الكثير من المراقبين والمحللين وحتى
المسؤولين في السودان هو امتداد للازمه
التي
حصلت في الخرطوم حاليا مقتل
والي غرب دارفور لماذا يصل الامر الى هذا
المستوى في عمليات القتل والتي اتهمت بعثه
الامم المتحده
قوه الدعم السريع بتنفيذه
هو هو لا يمكن فهم الصراع في الجنابه بعزل
عن هذا التاريخ بمعزل عن التركيبه
الاجتماعيه للولايه ويعزل عن الاحداث التي
حدثت سابقا وكذلك الذي جرى في الخرطوم هو
القى بظلاله بالطبع رفع غطاء الدوله عن
الجنين التي كانت جهود الرسميه تحاول
التخفيف من الصراع القبليه هناك يعني
التزام من قبل المجموعات الاهليه وصلوا
لاتفاق بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش الا
يخرج احد من سكنته ان تظل قوات الدعم
السريعه على مسافه وكذلك الجيش لكن لم
ينجحه في اخماد الصراع الاهلي اشتعل
الصراع الاهلي منذ اكثر من شهر حيث لا
توجد شبكه اتصال وكذلك خرجت اغلب يعني
منافذ الخدمه خرجت تماما عن الخدمه
وبالتالي هناك صراع اجتماعي تم استخدام
فيه كل انواع الاسلحه الحدود الفاصله بين
القبيله وبين المؤسسه الرسميه سواء كانت
الجيش او الدعم السرياح حتى الشرطه غير
واضحه تماما هناك تركيبه قبليه معقده لا
يمكن فهمهم
دارفور ومن هذه التركيبه القبليه اذا اذا
اخذنا بعين الاعتبار ما قلته ضمن هذه
التركيبه القتل القبليه اين
يوضع مقتل والي غرب دارفور
هناك محاوله من
الجهات الرسميه كلها لانقاذ الانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه لحمايه الوالي لكنها فشلت في
ظل التوتر الشديد وظل الاستقطاب والصراع
القبلي المجموعات التي لديها اشكالات
مجتماعيه اشكالات كبيره مع الوالي
كانت تصر على المضي قدما في اخذ الثار
الوالي كان يبدو ايضا جهود كبيره للعمل
نائبه من المجموعات العربيه وهو ينتمي الى
مجموعات المسالك لكن هذا لم ينجح في ظل
تواضع كبير هو كان يتحدث الى قناه فضائيه
الاصوات اصوات المعارك كانت الى جنبه كانت
القياده قياده الجيش ايضا لم تحرك ساكن
وهو رئيس لجنه الامن في الولايه كان ينبغي
ان توفر له الحمايه من هذا الصراع وكان هو
في موقف حرج جدا وفقدانه خساره كبيره
للمنطقه وخساره للدعم السريع نفسه وخساره
لعمليه السلام كان يعمل حتى اخر اللحظات
في النتيجه الاجتماع رفقه النسيج
الاجتماعي محاوله لم
خساره للدعم السريع الذي اتهمته لكن عفوا
خساره للدعم السريع الذي اتهمته بعثه
الامم المتحده بانها هي نقلا عن شهود عيان
بان قوات الدعم هي التي قتلت خميس اكبر
يعني الموضوع اصبح هنا متشابك سيد عبد
الماجد عبد الحميد
هل يمكن وضع هذا الامر في سياق صراع قبلي
موجود في في دارفور وبالتالي يعني صحيح
انما يحصل في الخرطوم ارخى بظلاله على
دارفور ولكن في النهايه المساله قبليه بحث
والجيش لم يؤمن سلامه والي غرب دارفور
لابد التعبير عن الحزن العميق للطريقه
البشعه التي بها
الوالي خميس وهي طريقه انا كما ذكرت صباح
اليوم ما تعيد السود الى مربع خطير جدا
وتفتح ابواب الفتنه من كل
جوانبها لكن لابد ايضا من الاشاره الى
قضيه هامه جدا وقع الطريق التي كانت تدار
بها ولايات دارفور عموما منذ توقيع الجبل
السلام
هذه الطريقه كانت تؤكد بانه هنالك يعني
الولايه يتصرفون بطريقه كانهم لا ينتمون
من الدوله المركزيه علاقه بالدوله
المركزيه انواع
نفسه
بطريقه غريبه جدا فهنالك ثقوب سياسيه وقود
تنفيذ امنيه في طريقه اداره ملف قبل وقوع
هذه العلاقات الموظفه لذلك ادى عاد الى ان
تتراقى قبضه الدوله المركزيه ليست حمايه
الوارده فقط انما حتى
ولذلك الذي جرى في الجنينه ويجري ايضا في
اخرى ونقيه طبيعيه
للنيابه قبضه الدوله المركزيه في التعامل
مع هذه الولايات وفشل
الحركات المسلحه التي وقعت السلام
التونسي
بالعاصمه وتحول عدد كبير جدا
الاعلاميين
عبر هذا التطبيق وهو عبر جدا عندما
احتدت الاوضاعتي الى الخرطوم عاد الى
دكتور
اخي قبله الدوله عفوا السيد عبد الماجد
سيد عبد الماجد تراخي قبضه الدوله على
دافور نتيجه ما يحصل في الخرطوم
وطريقه التعامل مع الازمه في في دارفور كل
هذا ادى الى ما وصلت اليه الامور ولكن
الى اي مدى هناك ارتباط مباشر بين الوضع
الميداني
الحاصل في الخرطوم وتصعيد الصراع بوجهه
القبلي في غرب دارفور
بصراحه ونحن هنا
نتحدث بصراحه هو انه يمكن اقول بانه تراخي
الجيش السوداني نفسه يحكم الامور الخرطوم
سيؤدي الى
الان في في ولايه في ولايه شمال كردفان
وما يمكن يجري في مناطق اخرى يهود بالدرجه
الاولى الى
تراخيصين الى تناسب قوات المسلحه بحسب
قضيه العاصمه وايضا
غياب السياسي
بصراحه عن مكون العسكري بدا جهد خرافي
بالقضاء على التمر شوكه الدعم السريعه
انتهى من الصوره الدعم السريع لكن هذه
القوه جزء كبير من الناس سياسي
السودان الان هو ان يعود مره اخرى الى ان
يتعامل مباشره مع حامله سياسيه قويه
تستطيع ان تستشرف ليس على المستوى الخارجي
نعم مرحبا بكم وبالساده المشاهدين
ولضيفيك الكريمين طبعا
ما يحدث في السودان هو
مؤسف جدا وتعازينا للفقيد
الاخوه السودانيين جميعا
طبعا هذه
الاحداث في اطار اطاله امد الحرب امد
الاشتباكات قلنا منذ الاسبوع الاول اذا
طالع امد الحرب والاشتباكات التي تحدث في
السودان فان ذلك كارثه كبيره
فهناك مقوله يرددها الناشطون ايضا
والخبراء والمحللون السياسيون بانه
السودان
الحكومه السودانيه وقعت اتفاق مع حركات
مسلحه وهي كثيره فهذه الحركات المسلحه
والفصائل والجهات
[موسيقى]
الاغتيالات لمن لا يريدون وقف هذه الحرب
هل ترى في مقتل والي غرب دارفور رساله
لاطراف معينه هل تفهم الموضوع في سياق
يعني نهج قد يكون هو سائد في المستقبل
القريب
النعم لا شك في ذلك خاصه حينما ننظر الى
انتماءات
الوالي القبليه وكذلك
كيفيه
الحادثه قيل انه بعد ان خرج من المقابله
في القناه الفضائيه وتحدث فيها
وانتقد جهه بعينها حدث ما حدث لا شك في ان
هذا رساله للاطراف الاخرى ايضا التي ربما
تريد ان تقف مع الحكومه السودانيه واي طرف
اخر اذن هذا
فهذا السبب في انني قلته بانه ربما يكون
هذا بدايه
اغتيالات ولاجراءات جديده سواء يعني من
الطرفين لا اريد ان اذكر هنا جهه بعينها
لكن هذا مؤشر خطير في فتح باب
السودان امام السودان باب العوده وان
القطار يمر سريعا يبتعد سريعا من امام
السودانيين ولا يدركوا ان يجلسوا غدا
للحوار او العوده لمسار المفاوضات فهذه
خطوره كبيره لابدل السودانيون سواء في
الخرطوم او في
اسمح لي انتقل الى حافظ كبير من جديد في
الخرطوم طيب هذا الذي حصل في حصل ويحصل في
الجنينه في ولايه غرب دارفور عموما كيف
سينعكس على اتفاق سلام دارفور وايضا كيف
سينعكس على المشهد الاقتتال الحاصل في
الخرطوم برايك لكن باختصار ارجوك
هو بالطبع هو
امر كبير ومؤسف
يتم اغتيال شخص كبير مثل خميس وهو رئيس
كتله كبيره التحالف السوداني احد اعمده
الاطراف السلام لكن هذا جانب ينبغي ان
ينبه الاطراف كلها لضروره ايقاف الحرب هذا
الجانب الاهم وبالتالي الاتفاق السلامه
الان اطرافه انقسمت بعضها على مسافه اقرب
للجيش والبعض الاخر على مسافه اقرب
للمكونات المدنيه التي تؤيد العمليه
السياسيه التي كانت تمضي نحو خواتيمها
اعتقد ان مساله الاتفاق السلام منذ مجيء
الاطراف الى الداخل حدثت فيها اشكالات
كبيره جدا وبالتالي تحتاج الى مراجعه هناك
ورشه عقدت من اجل مراجعه تنفيذ اتفاق
السلام هناك خلل كبير في تنفيذ الترتيبات
الامنيه هذا كله لا يمكن ان يتحقق ما لم
توقف الحرب التي تجري الان كان يمكن ان
يساهم اتفاق السلام مساهمه كبيره في حمايه
المدنيين في دارفور هناك اليات معلومه
ومتفق عليها لكنها تفتقد الان الى الاراده
السياسيه كذلك تفتقد الى الموارد وتفتقد
الى الهياكل التي ينبغي ان تقيمها مؤسسه
معترف بها ولديها الشرعيه هذا كله غايب
الان وبالتالي يطرح هذا التحدي سؤال
الحكومه الشرعيه الحكومه المدنيه المقبله
ينبغي عليها الاستفاده من هذا الدرس كذلك
يطرح هذا الامر يعني ضروره ان تحل مساله
السلام في اطار اشمل وليست في اطار
مجموعات الان نحن لدينا مجموعات كثيره
متعدده كما ذكر ضيفك الكريم هي كلها
تتقاسم قضايا وتتقاسم السلطه وكذلك تتقاسم
القضيه الكبيره التي من اجلها قامت الحرب
في دارفور كانت هذه الحركات كلها حركه
واحده الان ينبغي ان يكون هناك قضيه
يعني نعم
موضوع اكثر من التركيز على الاطراف اتفاق
السلام في دارفور يترنح الان باعتبار ان
اطرافه انقسموا بانقسام الجيش والدعم
السريع وبالتالي الامور مرشحه للتصعيد
هنا سيد عبد المجيد
سؤالي لك الى اي مدى هذا الموضوع يمكن ان
يفتح صراعات اخرى ويمكن ان يذهب نحو
التصعيد اكثر
وبالتالي تضيق فسحه الامل في وضع حد لهذا
الاقتتال الذي نشب في في الخرطوم وبدا
يتسع
بسيط ومعقد في هذا الوقت بسيط في ان نعيد
النظر مره اخرى لان الطريقه التي كان يدير
بها الشركاء اذا كانت الجانب العسكريه
والجانب المدني تعالوا يديرون العميد
السودان بطريقه استقبال اوله الشهاده
السياسي وهذه الطريقه بين استجباره
السودان الى هذه الحرب الان المخرج في ان
يتعقل هؤلاء الذين لهذه الدرجه
وعلم يذهبوا الى تطبيق
الجانب الايجابي في المصفوفه او في
المقترحات التي قدمت الوساطه ولكن
بالتحديد الان يعني عفوا نريد نريد ان
نستشرف ما الذي سيحصل في القريب ما الذي
سيحصل برايك على مستوى هذا الصراع مع
اتساعه بهذا الشكل واخذه هذه الاشكال من
التصعيد مساله الاغتيالات للاطراف غير
المؤيده لهذا الطرف او ذاك
بكل صراحه وامانه وكل حزن هذه الطريقه اذا
استمرت ولهذا الاتحاد والتراخي ايضا في
حسم هذه القضيه العسكريه وقود هذا الامر
الى ان تتفاعل الامور في السودان والسودان
دوري
الشهاده لا تتحمل الكثير جدا جدا في هذه
الاحداث الساخنه اذا لم حكم صناعه الخرطوم
باعدل ما تيسر اقول ما تيسر وفي ظل غياب
القبض المركزيه على خليط الهشه ايكون
السودان في امام خليج ساخن يكون مستقبل
السودان كله في امام معدل الريح وهي لحظه
تاريخيه تطلب
منكر مره اخرى قناه السودان والحريصين على
استقرار هذا البلد ان يذهبوا بالبحث عن
طريقه اخرى وعن مخرج اخر الخروج الذي
ادخلتنا فيه
الكارثه شكرا لك عبد المجيد عبد الحميد
الكاتب والمحليل السياسي من الخرطوم شكرا
لموسى شيخو الباحث والكاتب المختص في
الشؤون الافريقيه من اديس ابابا وشكرا
لحافظ كبير الكاتب والبحث السياسي كان
معنا من الخرطوم
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]